foreign
[Music]
[Music]
so
yes
[Music]
12.
[Music]
[Music]
uh
addis ababa capital of ethiopia
a mass of humanity gathers for the
festival of epiphany
just another face in the watching crowd
awol mela knows
that the vast majority of those
celebrating today will return home to
their villages
facing poverty and hardship
he believes that the rich countries of
the world have failed africa
and that the time has come to change
i often wonder if the rich countries
stop patronizing africans
and realize that given the opportunity
it's
africans themselves who will take the
continent out of poverty
despite the hundreds of billions of
dollars donated
and thousands of foreign aid workers the
situation has actually got worse
he doesn't deny the corruption of
african governments but blames the
developed world for failing to direct
its aid to the people who actually need
it on the ground
i don't know how much of that money has
come to ethiopia
people say billions and billions i think
it is fair to calculate
how much of that has trickled down the
money
has been spent in different ways
salaries big offices somewhere in europe
or highly paid expatriates
if that money comes directly to farmers
it can change the way they live
a woe understands the meaning of poverty
he lost his father when very young
and it was his mother who struggled to
find the money to educate him
well we had our own small farms
and she did all what she could
to raise me and i know it was difficult
for her that's why i say
she was wonderful it was not easy
at that time to
grow without a father because you should
have had you know
i should have had a model
as he grew from boy to man he became
increasingly frustrated at the lack of
progress in ethiopia
decades passed yet the daily plight of
his countrymen appeared stuck in a time
warp
he's convinced that a good part of the
blame lies at the door of foreign
agencies
development agencies have the tendency
to tell people what they should do
rather than working with the people
they have the tendency to impose their
own thinkings
and their own approach and that has
never worked
and it will not work
he began to ask where was the logic of
foreigners building a school in a rural
area
if there was no health care and the
children were too sick or too hungry to
attend
why give farmers free seeds when the
topsoil has washed away and nothing will
grow
he feels it's time that outsiders who
don't understand the real needs of
africans
stop imposing their solutions and start
asking africans themselves what they
think is needed
virtually unknown to the rest of the
world five years ago
he began a huge experiment in the sodor
region of central ethiopia
it lies within the great rift valley and
has been frequently blighted by famine
his aim to persuade a quarter of a
million people living here
to stop accepting free handouts and work
their
own way out of poverty he calls it
self-help we don't give things free of
charge
giving things free of charge is creating
dependencies in realm
but our philosophy is that if people
want to be helped they have to help
themselves that's
really important his initial plan was
simple
teach 20 men and women new skills on
agreement that they each teach
20 more their followers who in turn
teach 20 more and so on today those
followers already number
tens of thousands
[Music]
for the last two years our cameras have
tracked progress of the experiment
we follow the stories of people like
amini indele
mulugeta hailu and amaric doyo
desperate to succeed where past
generations had failed
and we found others equally determined
to destroy the experiment
in order to protect their own interests
money lenders used to living off the
backs of the poor
angry their businesses threatened
thieves robbing the hillsides of what
few trees remain
farmers stealing water from their
neighbors
and even a rebellion amongst the people
of one devastated region
where the men are refusing to work
without free food
persuade a community which has become
dependent on foreign aid for over half a
century
to change its ways and can they do it
for a fraction of the normal cost
without any help from foreign aid
workers
[Music]
contrary to popular image many rural
areas of ethiopia are fertile especially
in the wet season
it's a country which should in normal
circumstances
be able to provide enough food for its
population
drought is often just around the corner
[Music]
when that happens crops are destroyed
livestock die
and hunger returns
just ask the people of sodor region how
many have lost family members to famine
or disease
every one of you
[Music]
the major reason behind the great
famines is the reliance on just one crop
maize when that fails everyone is
vulnerable
abuule gizo is a prime example
life is already hard but should a
drought descend
his family faces months of hunger
um
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
do was counter the constant threat of
famine
the answer lay in just one extraordinary
plant
[Applause]
ethiopians call nset the magic plant
it's one of the most versatile plants
imaginable every part having a purpose
previously it could only grow high up in
the mountains
but self-help introduced a hybrid for
the lowland plains
it needs very little water and can
produce bread
and dumplings with the residue used for
porridge
even its leaves can be stripped to make
ropes
but its most important feature is its
longevity
people here can bury the plant for up to
seven years without any spoiling
just one of these parcels can feed a
family of six for a month
in times of drought they simply dig it
up and it's as good to eat as the day it
was buried
this was one of the first groups of
followers taught insect cultivation
to ward off the threat of starvation
and today the plant can be found in
farms stretching across the region
survival is one thing but if the local
economy was ever going to change
the farmers had to stop growing just
enough food for their own families
and start producing cash crops others
was one of the first to be taught how to
develop a nursery
creating a mixture of seedlings
including peppers onions and coffee
he now sells to neighbors
sharing his knowledge has become just
another part of the business
there's a simple logic the more farmers
he teaches
the more by his seedlings
that's all changing but in a way that no
one here ever expected
until very recently sodor region was
like virtually everywhere else
entirely dominated by men
but in a role reversal the likes of
which the continent has never seen
it's women who now control family income
a savings and credit scheme just like
micro
has been set up and only women are
allowed to borrow money
[Music]
apparently men could no longer be
[Music]
trusted
wife abrihet came up with the idea of
building a restaurant in the middle of
the countryside
many thought she was mad
but while local incomes rise as the
experiment gathers pace
it seems to be working
thousands of women have joined the
scheme
they borrow money at low interest rates
to buy sheep or cattle
or even seeds for their farmer husbands
to grow
from those they make a profit pay back
their loan
and can then borrow more to expand their
business
but there's one man who wishes they'd
never started
tadale fikadu
[Music]
foreign
foreign
was one of the first to join the
experiment now she teaches her own
followers how to stand
up for themselves
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
despite no formal education it's a
marriage who now travels to the local
town to negotiate new funds for the
women's cooperative
something which would have been unheard
of just a few years ago
our marriage is a great personality
she's really extraordinary
at the beginning when we came here
most of the women we see were shy
but i think slowly the shyness
has disappeared our marriage should be
proud
because of her hard work she has
given opportunity to her children and
there is no better reason
than this
foreign
foreign
with family planning a key part of the
experiment
for the first time in living memory the
birth rate in this region
is beginning to fall but if amaric's
children are to get the chance to
fulfill their aspirations
they'll be forced to leave the region
there's only an elementary school nearby
the nearest high school
is 30 kilometers away and only a very
few parents can afford to send their
children there
bye bye bye
bye say bye the local people have been
raising money to build one
but it's still a distant dream
what's this
again an area of land has been set aside
for the project
but the school will have to wait
through the morning mist on a
mountaintop high above the great rift
valley
worshipers gather to pray
[Music]
as the mist clears one of the most
devastated regions of ethiopia
emerges below
this is the area of sodor region known
as the watershed
when the wet season arrives vast amounts
of precious rainwater
rush off the mountainside ripping the
topsoil from the land
before pouring uselessly into a distant
[Music]
river
an area which used to be lush with
vegetation
has become almost a desert
over 10 000 people rely on just one well
and the nearest water has to be pumped
from almost 300 meters below the surface
once that area was densely forested
but as time passed on the trees were
gone
the top soil which is important to grow
crops was exposed to
erosion and farmers in that area
were not able to grow food something has
to change
but our wool mail is determined that the
farmers must do it themselves
[Music]
from all over the watershed area they've
come together
to block the water rushing off the
mountain forcing it to seep into the
ground
only that way can they begin to raise
the water table to a level where they
can get to it easily
[Music]
sooner
[Applause]
uh
um
in the past work was rewarded with free
food from other agencies in return
but are wolves determined to get them
out of their dependency syndrome
behind the scenes though some of the
farmers leaders
are far from happy
is
things aren't going well either for
amaric doyle and her fellow committee
members on the savings and credit scheme
some women have failed to pay back the
money they borrowed
the committee will have to decide either
to give them more time
or send them to court
if they take no action others will think
they can get away with it too
much
as the others give their reasons for
non-payment it's clear the committee is
split
and is
[Music]
should they fail they'll face court
action and they all have to sign their
agreement to this
keeping a tight rein on the little money
they have is important for lots of
reasons
not least because of the need to raise
funds for the high school
and other vital projects
solomon cabelle has recently been made
head of the new health clinic
in the town of keller
catering for up to 40 000 people it's
the first of its kind in sodor region
[Music]
previously these patients would have to
walk 20 kilometers to get proper medical
care
before the clinic local people were at
the mercy of drug sellers
charging up to 10 times what the drugs
were actually worth
now through their own pharmacy they get
them virtually at cost
it's a similar story at the regional
hospital which again
the people themselves built
when self-help first came to sodo they
struck a deal with local government
if the people gather money and help
build schools and hospitals
the authorities will pay staff and
maintenance costs
due to the absence of a hospital around
the people were obliged to go to
either to add this hundred
fifty kilometer or two hosanna from
bhutaj 100 kilometers
you can't imagine how serious was
the health problem in this area over a
million people
including many outside the self-help
area can now use its facilities
major diseases of the region are mainly
of that of respiratory like tb pneumonia
in malaria malaria also is prevalent in
most of the lowland areas
it is a community's commitment
that was giving us energy
to achieve this hospital construction
and give service
to the community itself
but while the hospital is running
smoothly elsewhere in sodor
not everything is going to plan
[Music]
the watershed project is an imminent
danger of collapse
just 18 months before the water table
lay almost 300 meters below the ground
they dug dams and trenches to allow
rainwater to seep into the ground
and the table to rise
the water table increased to 30 meters
as time goes on still
the water table will increase and
probably to
10 meters and 15 meters so that farmers
will be able
to access water very easily
before the project began farmers were
getting free food from america and
canada for any work they did
world wants them to work without
handouts
the majority of farmers have accepted it
and
in fact they have worked quite a lot
some farmers who are
trying to bring problems so that the
others
should not do this without footage
a meeting of the farmers committee has
been called and a woe has brought his
own team with him
um
it's easy to see why he's reluctant no
matter how much our walls people tell
him the water table is rising
he can see no evidence on the wasteland
that surrounds his home
the meeting breaks up without resolution
the entire project could be in jeopardy
[Music]
the man who spoke in favor of working
without free food
is amini indeli
albatuno
if the farmers at the watershed could
work together
a world knows that they could have the
same success as others
all over the region workers cooperatives
have sprung up
this land was barren before self-help
introduced an irrigation system
[Music]
um
[Music]
back at the self-help regional office
the team have hardly had time to focus
on dealing with the watershed rebellion
when another crisis arises
well we got a problem farmers are
stealing water from other farmers
and we have to go and fix it right now
there is a big problem down there
and unless we solve it it will get more
problems than it will solve
the irrigation system had been
introduced to help a large group of
farmers maximize their growing
even in dry periods
it's changed not only the landscape but
the lives of those living there
but apparently one of the cooperatives
members has been sneaking out at night
to divert extra water to his own plot
[Music]
what may seem to outsiders a small local
issue
is a matter of survival here
once again our wool has to try and stop
things getting out of hand
some of the farmers want to
the other farmers want to throw the
thief off the irrigated land
this cooperative has brought life to the
people here
and if the man is thrown out he's going
to lose all the privilege
as a committee member and he will go
back
to poverty again this is the worst kind
of penalty they will put
on him
and this is what it's all about
the entire region has been transformed
by individual
entrepreneurs and farmers working in
cooperatives
average incomes have quadrupled and
everywhere
exotic produce rarely seen in this part
of the world before
is for sale
[Music]
even the government's own tax man has
come down to collect
but those outside the project can only
dream of such things
who grows only maize and whose family
exists on bread alone
that's because they live on the wrong
side of the road
literally on the other side haptic
argor's farm
falls just within the self-help borders
he too once lived on nothing but bread
but now grows onions
peppers potatoes and a whole mixture of
cash crops he sells to the market
through the profit he made he just had a
water hole dug in his field
ensuring that even a severe drought
won't destroy his crops
his family lives well and his children
go to school
[Music]
like millions of africans abu lei simply
wants the same chance
it's not just about survival it's about
pride
foreign
compare his plight to our marriage doyle
with the profit she's made from selling
her farm produce
she's paid for a well to be installed in
her garden
now she proudly shows it off to her 20
followers
[Music]
foreign are exciting times too
at the hailu family restaurant
a new roof is in place new furniture on
order and highly unusual in this part of
the country
the traditional mud floor is being
replaced by a solid one made of cement
[Music]
for abrihet and her husband mulugeta
life today
has changed beyond recognition but this
is a couple who have made a virtue
of waiting for great things to happen
[Music]
they are great husbands and wives let me
tell you
and they are the shining stars
for that community and the community has
seen them
coming out of poverty and they are good
example
as long as people work hard they can
come out of poverty
and the children of the region have
something else to look forward to
themselves
today is a proud day for the people of
sodor
thousands have come together because at
last
enough money has been raised to lay the
foundations of a very special building
the new high school is about to take
shape
[Music]
for over three years they've been
raising funds through selling food from
their farms
making clothes and even collecting
door-to-door
they did it themselves and now at last
they're about to see the reward for
their efforts my goodness
it's a great day for all of us i am
really delighted to have
such number of people to come here
[Music]
but not everyone is celebrating three
months
have passed and two of the six women who
had failed to pay back their loans to
the women's cooperative
couldn't meet the new deadline
weinster demisi used the money she
borrowed to open a restaurant
to provide for her two children one of
them disabled
vietnamese vietnamese
was doing well selling goods at the
market until her husband threw her and
her children out of their home after an
argument
but
[Music]
is concerned that others may fail to pay
unless the committee takes a tough
stance
it looks as though both women will face
legal action
their children may be forced to leave
school and end up on the streets
then a final compromise is found
they'll be allowed two
[Music]
[Music]
back at the watershed the progress of
the work done before the rebellion can
be seen
as green vegetation begins sprouting
again over the plains
[Music]
a whole mailer has been working
desperately to bring the farmers back
as he looks around he notices that the
ring leaders have not turned up
but those who have seemed determined to
continue
even without them
but
that the future is entirely in their
hands
although there's still no sign of the
ringleaders hundreds have turned up to
dig the next barriers to the flooding
waters
then without warning jember adani and
the other would-be rebellion leaders
come walking up the hill digging tools
in hand
foreign
[Music]
hello
without a foreign aid worker in sight
and for 30 times less than the cost of a
similar project of this magnitude
almost a quarter of a million african
people are grabbing the opportunity
to get themselves out of extreme poverty
the markets are full of new products and
a new generation of entrepreneurs is
building for the future
new schools are rising from the earth to
raise the aspirations of the young
along with hospitals and clinics
dramatically improving the health of the
region
even the threat of famine has been
greatly reduced
with the introduction of an almost
magical plant
africans helping africans
neighbors helping neighbours
immense pride returning to a people who
are changing their own destinies
yet not far outside the self-help
borders
poverty is there for all to see
these people are asking why not
[Music]
us
nobody knows the problem better than the
africans
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]